whoo do you think you'll cut this always
true my wife is looking for those don't
cut that please don't let that mr.
wanted it's time to finish this carbon
fiber project let's start with the brick
3:30 p.m. and we're at Lancaster
California and here with Matt Michaels
one of the editors on lifelines going
today
where's Lancaster what is the middle an
hour dude it's where the desert start we
are here today to film some guerilla
style pickup shots we're not really
pushing the boundaries of filmmaking
right now thrown a red camera yeah we're
still in shock three shots basically
shooting just called vacuum bagging
Mather game-planning ollie before we had
a nice night so any night thank you
that's the woods enough fabric there
okay and as a reminder carbon fiber is a
mixture of how you just you just peel it
off you didn't have this there that
would be one with your part ah pretty
okay yeah good like who appointed mmm
yeah great carbon fibers yeah the Java
this plastic was to hopefully get a nice
smooth surface on the other side of the
carbon we can ensure I made another down
the street from a place that makes
another glassy shirt thank you
this is be pretty sighs whoa well
and I'm happy that this plastic actually
works like a charm except you turned
that into the knife yeah I want the
biggest knife we can get here how how
strong is this it's pretty it's pretty
intense not ideal for flying drones in
the air and I don't know I don't know
how that's gonna go
if you like watching us operate
expensive equipment in dangerous
situations don't forget to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]
okay yeah yeah so be a little app to
made me confirm that I have permission
to find his dairy I think we might be
closer than airport well yeah he would
enter dentists right yeah cannot see
that's the exact same car for
Michelle yeah yeah it was impossible to
duplicate it we took a while to get them
to let us have it back okay we're good
on the speed controls this so we're
talking not where this way I can tell by
your face you're smiling honey goes damn
pretty good pretty good
hey this video is brought to you today
by audible when I used to have to drive
to work
I would usually listen to a book in the
car it was really really nice I heard a
bunch of great stories and it was really
cool having you the author or some great
British vocal performer usually read the
book do all the different voices it's
like having an HBO miniseries for your
book today I want to recommend to you a
certain specific book that is on audible
and it is Ender's Game it is my favorite
book of all time a few decades ago earth
was attacked and they have been
scrambling ever since to put together
the ultimate tactical genius this kid
has been genetically modified and bred
and groomed to grow up to become this
tactical genius of course he's still a
human being he's caught in the middle of
all this B's struggling with the
responsibility in the way of saving the
planet but that's not why it's my
favorite book of all time I'm a huge
action fan I love action movies I love
action scenes I love it when they are
done well and they tell a story which is
very hard to find these days
Ender's Game has the best character and
story driven action scenes in anything
I've read or watched the way ender
approaches these tactical situations
that have been set up to be unfair
challenges towards them is impeccably
written you learn about the character
you learn about these scenes like
riveting and exciting and you can check
it all out on audible yet read the book
and you are driving or your levels in
the podcast or you're sitting on your
desk when you're working you want to
listen to something go sign up for a 30
day trial it's free at audible.com/asap
amigo
tell me what you think I would love to
hear what you guys think about Ender's
Game it is after all my favorite book of
all time
and I'd love to share that joy with all
of you so audible.com slash Sam and eco
there's a link in the description below
and with that back to our regularly
scheduled linear algebra and material
science mechanical engineering yes if
you guys think you're up to the task on
figuring out exactly how strong this is
there are 24 layers
12 remaining from this orientation and
then the other orientation 0 90 + + - 45
well the stacking sequence matters too
because every other it's every other
will probably happened as I have two
identical layers in the middle you
repeat the very center of the part I got
you I guess what type of carbon fiber is
the select every manufacturer has
different specs general sects I can say
as those each yarn is 3k that's the 3000
fiber it's a 5.7 a 23 yards like 9
inches 4 inch does 6.7 3 millimeters in
thickness so quarter-inch so in theory
using those input variables they can
figure out exactly how much strength it
was required to snap it like this ok so
you guys want to make one the same size
of this look at all this back - let's
now you guys can make them which are
going to be defense though I think
normally traveler Olympic 291 to half
the million dollar question when was the
last time the filter 14 store you want
me to be a sardine oh all right
[Music]
such as part of the entire process we're
going to try to do the belt sander that
we'll just plant to the table to make a
blade today is Friday 2017 and it's the
time when we take a moment to recognize
our beautiful patrons Tristan Gore
Timothy Thompson John wick so hull I
James Bailey Brian and Togiak Richard
Blackbird that is so much dust in it you
guys helped make these videos possible
thank you very much
II
we have made nine oh my god
we're pretty - I wouldn't put this stuff
up yeah block it keep it up this is how
I chose the bull tonight my ears are
ringing from that oh my god your face
should I got a nice the name la voz
turned out yeah you rounded your handle
more than I did
yeah this wood stabbed and killed last
night
well what hey dude with this you might
actually break the tip let's not
actually stab things with it I feel like
we should cut something I could probably
cut a Peter let's not stab her cut
anything he just the tip on this already
I use a car - so getaway car let me ask
you a serious question
we're making knives out of carbon fiber
but they can't cut anything I think you
need why are we making eyes at a carbon
fiber
are they good throwing knife what to
think these are good like sneak him on
an airplane can I hold on we know how
this videos gonna end
oh I had a little pocket knife on me and
then the guy was like oh we will keep
this at the front desk for you so you
can grab it on your way out
come back and he's like we don't know
where it went my guess is expensive nice
yes is being expensive is $60 no knives
are made for one thing yes Allanon yeah
they're like oh sure you like dinner
nice guy it's like breathing my knives
are made out of natural freaking me out
home to happen if you are anxious I cut
the old box of jelly
Prince knocks backyard got his box of
junk back here here I'm in it back there
ready box hey my buck how you
doing what up is always true my wife is
looking for those don't cut that please
don't cut that mister sorry Jenna I'm
sorry balls cover with the custard
Jenna's Tupperware that I've been having
hidden back here for a year
Jake's kind of scaring me just a little
bit so great
did you get that what did you wear that
shirt today thank you
yeah yeah figures no this is it huh
oh my who got me earlier I'm on edge man
I'm on edge was super cool we've made
carbon fiber knives yeah that's the
coolest thing ever but now we have one
more carbon fiber thing to make
absolutely still started for you to see
that you got to subscribe and find out
next time on the team nico-chan
[Music]